[Music]
Today we're reviewing AMD's new Radeon
RX 960 XT which is available in 8 and 16
GB configurations. And for this review
we are looking at the 16 GB models. I
will be tearing apart the 8 GB version
in a video tomorrow. So don't worry, but
I'm not going to waste too much time
discussing it in this video. rather
focus will be on the only version you
should buy, which is of course the 16 GB
version. But before we get to that,
today's sponsor spot is brought to you
by Anttech and their Flux Pro Full Tower
case. This addition to Ant's lineup
integrates real timber on the front
panel as well as a textured
multi-directional front grill, giving it
a unique style while ensuring optimal
air flow. As the name suggests, the Flux
Pro offers Antex patented dual lower air
intake design and includes support for
up to nine fans with six PWM fans
pre-installed with a built-in ARGB
controller. The Flux Pro also supports
up to 420 mm radiators in the top and
front and includes various cooling
brackets to facilitate easy
installation. Not only are these cases
chart topping when it comes to thermal
performance, they're also available at
an excellent price. So, for more
information, please check the link in
the video
description. AMD announced the 960 XT
series during their Computex keynote,
and we dedicated a video to covering it.
But I'll quickly go over the specs
again, and then we'll get into the
testing. So, first and foremost, the
MSRP for the 16 GB model has been set at
$350 US, which is an almost 20% discount
when compared to the 16 GB RTX 5060Ti.
And that's despite the die size being
10% larger, though AMD's no doubt saved
a bit of money by sticking with the
older GDDR6X memory. Now, when compared
to the previous generation 7600 XT, the
core configuration remains the same, but
of course, the 960 XT is based on the
RDNA4 architecture, and the cores
themselves are clocking 14% higher.
AMD's also gone with the higher clocked
20 Gbits pers memory, increasing the
memory bandwidth by 11% to 320 GB pers.
The PCI interface has been updated to
the 5.0 spec and the full 16 lanes are
available, though right now this is of
little benefit for the 16 GB model as
you shouldn't be able to exceed that
capacity under realistic conditions. So,
that's a very brief overview of the 960
XT 16 GB. Now, I'll be taking the ASRock
Steel Legend version and throwing in our
test system because ASRock handed it to
us at Computex. So, it was the first one
that I managed to get my hands on. But,
I do also have the ASUS Prime and
Sapphire Nitro Plus models, which we can
take a look at towards the end of the
review. Okay, let's get to it. Starting
with clear obscure expedition 33, the
960 XT was 5% slower than the 5060 Ti.
Though using the epic preset, neither
GPU was particularly impressive at
1440p, so you either need to enable
upscaling or lower the quality settings.
Frame rates were closer to 60fps at
1080p, though the margin was much the
same. So, for the purpose of working out
how these two GPUs compare, the 1440p
data is suitable. Performance in
Oblivion Remastered is also pretty weak
at native 1440p using the ultra preset,
just 41 FPS on average. Though that did
make the 960 XT 11% faster than the 5060
Ti. Delta Force is a much easier title
to run, allowing the 9060 XT to deliver
105 FPS at 1440p, though that did make
it 10% slower than the 5060 Ti. We're
looking at 4060 Ti light performance in
this example, which shockingly made the
9060 XT a mere 6% faster than the old
RTX 3060 Ti. Stalker 2 is playable on
the 9060 XT when maxed out at 1440p,
though you would probably enable
upscaling here to hit at least 60 fps.
Anyway, in this example, the 9060 XT and
5060 Ti are neck andneck with just over
40 FPS.
Moving on to Counter-Strike 2, we've
seen some performance improvements for
the Blackwell GPUs with recent driver
updates, but sadly no such gains have
been seen for RDNA4, and as a result,
the 9060 XT ends up being 17% slower
than the 5060 Ti with 331 FPS on
average. So, still great performance,
but not nearly as good as what we're
seeing from the GeForce
competitor. Next up, we have Space
Marine 2. And here, the Blackwell GPUs
have again received a nice performance
boost with the more recent driver
releases. And as a result, the 960 XT
ends up 13% slower than the 5060 Ti with
66 FPS on average. So, similar
performance to that of the 7700 XT and
RTX 3070.
The 9060 XTE is again slower than the
5060 Ti. This time in Star Wars Jedi
Survivor where it trailed by an 8%
margin at 1440p which also meant it was
8% slower than the 7700 XT. So a pretty
disappointing result
there. Of course, as usual, the Radeon
GPUs crushed the Call of Duty benchmark
this time when testing with Black Ops 6.
Here, the 960 XT was a massive 32%
faster than the 560Ti and even outpaced
the 7700 XT by a 10% margin. The new
Radeon GPU also performed well in a
plaguetail reququum, beating the 5060 Ti
by a slim 3% margin. So, in other words,
both GPUs delivered the exact same
experience in this title. The Starfield
performance isn't too bad. And this is
another example where upscaling would
push performance above 60 fps. Still,
the 9060 XT did end up 6% slower than
the 5060 Ti, delivering the exact same
performance seen from the RTX 3070, 7700
XT, and 4060 Ti. So, pretty
underwhelming
really. Next up, we have Cyberpunk 2077.
And here, the 9060 XT and 5060 Ti are
very similar in terms of performance
with the Radeon GPU trailing by a mere
2% margin. So, when compared to previous
generation parts, we're looking at 7700
XT and RTX 4070 light performance. In
this example, the 9060 XT performed well
in God of War Ragnarok, rendering 101
FPS on average at 1440p, making it a few
frames faster than the 5060 Ti. So, we
have yet another example where
performance is much the same between
these two GPUs.
Unfortunately for AMD, we benchmarked
Dying Light 2 using the high preset,
which defaults to the DirectX11 API, and
this is just how the game works, and we
don't manually adjust settings to favor
one brand over the other, or at least
appear to be doing so. But if you have a
Radeon GPU, I highly recommend manually
switching to DirectX12, as this does
improve performance quite a bit. But if
you don't do this, the 9060 XT ends up
18% slower than the 5060 Ti under the
same conditions, whereas performance
between the two will be similar with
DirectX12. Now, we have already seen a
number of examples where the 960 XT and
5060 Ti are very similar in terms of
performance. And we have yet another
example, this time in Dragon Age, the
Valgard, where the Radeon GPU is just 3%
slower.
Spider-Man Remastered is another example
where performance is very similar
between these two GPUs. And
impressively, that meant the new 960 XT
was 10% faster than the 7800
XT. Next up, we have Hogwarts Legacy.
And here, the 960 XT was able to nudge
ahead of the 5060Ti by 5% margin. So
again, performance is very similar
between the two. And performance in
general was very good at 1440p using the
high preset. Performance is also
comparable in The Last of Us Part One.
Here, the 1960 XT was 7% slower than the
5060Ti, but with an average of 65 FPS at
1440p using the ultra quality settings.
Performance overall was decent and
better than that of the 7700 XT. And in
fact, considerably better when comparing
the 1%
lows. Finally, we have Star Wars
Outlaws. And here performance was much
the same with the 960 XT rendering just
a single extra frame when compared to
the 5060 Ti. Though performance overall
was quite poor as this isn't the most
optimized game out there. Okay, so
although we didn't look at the 1080p
results on a per game basis, I have the
averages, so we might as well just
quickly look at those. For gaming at
1080p, the 960 XT and 5060 Ti are fairly
evenly matched. though the Radeon GPU
was 6% slower overall, which meant it
was just 4% faster than the 7700 XT. So,
in other words, it's kind of like a 7700
XT, but with far better RT performance,
FSR4 support, and more VRAM. So,
arguably, it is a reasonable upgrade.
Oh, and it's also cheaper, or at least
it should be. The 1440p data is a little
more favorable to the 9060 XT as here
it's just a frame or a percent slower
than the 5060 Ti. So, that's a pretty
great result given it should cost almost
20% less. Though, please note I am
saying should. Anyway, this is again the
same level of performance you can expect
from the 7700 XT. Okay, so time to look
at ray tracing performance and what we
believe are truly transformative
examples. Starting with Allen Wake 2. At
1080p with upscaling, the performance
isn't good. just 31 FPS on average,
making the 5060Ti significantly faster.
Though, I'm not sure I'd want to play at
1080p with DLSS upscaling with just 46
FPS on average. I think at that point,
I'd rather just disable the RTFX
altogether. Next, we have Cyberpunk
2077. And performance here is a lot
better, but even so, we are just at an
upscaled 1080p resolution. So, 64 fps
isn't exactly amazing. And again, I
think you just play this one without
rateracing enabled or heavily reduced.
The 960 XT was 14% slower than the 5060
Ti. And even the 74 FPS from the GeForce
GPU is not particularly good because
again, this is upscaled 1080p. Moving to
1440p reduced the 5060 Ti to just 49
FPS. So again, neither GPU is really
able to deliver a transformative RT
experience in Cyberpunk.
Spider-Man Remastered is a well
optimized RT title. And here both GPUs
performed very well, delivering 123 FPS
on average. So, we might as well look at
the 1440p results for this example. Here
we're looking at 88 FPS from the 9060 XT
and 90 FPS from the 5060 Ti. So, again,
both did perform very well. We have
Dying Light 2. And while 75 fps seems
decent, this is upscaled 1080p, so don't
get too excited. I don't think either
the 9060 XT nor the 5060Ti are
particularly impressive here, though the
Radeon GPU was 9% slower. And at 1440p
with higher quality upscaling, both did
fall short of
60fps. The 960 XT was good for just 26
fps on average at upscaled 1080p in
Blackm Wukong when using the very high
quality ray tracing option. So, in other
words, not really playable. That also
made it roughly 50% slower than the 5060
Ti, though the GeForce GPU only managed
51 FPS, so sub-optimal performance given
the resolution. It's a similar story in
Indiana Jones and the Great Circle.
Here, the 9060 XT averaged just 23 FPS.
And while that meant it was 45% slower
than the 5060 Ti, just 42 FPS for the
GeForce GPU was hardly impressive.
Older titles with impressive rate
tracing, such as Metro Exodus Enhanced,
do play well on the 960 XT. Here we're
looking at 152 FPS on average, making it
just 4% slower than the 5060 Ti.
Overall, the 960 XT was 20% slower on
average when compared to the 5060 Ti for
our RA tracing tests with an average of
65 FPS. That said, for the most part,
neither GPU is able to deliver a
transformative experience. And in the
older games where they can, performance
was very
similar. Now, when it comes to power
consumption, the 960 XT is about what
you'd expect, consuming slightly more
power than the 7600 XT and Starfield,
and around 10% more than the 560 Ti. So,
a 26 watt increase. Also, please note
we're combining power draw from the CPU
and GPU here, as this allows us to
account for any overhead. The power
results in Star Wars Outlaws look much
the same. the 960 XT consuming 27 watts
more than the 5060 Ti, which is an 11%
increase. And again, it consumes
slightly more power than the 7600 XT.
Then finally, we have some power figures
from our Space Marine 2 testing. And in
this example, the 9060 XT consumed 21
watts more than the RTX 5060Ti, which
works out to be an 8% increase in this
example.
Okay, so here's a quick look at how the
partner cards I have on hand performed
under the same test conditions, which
was a 1-hour load test in the new F-125
game when installed inside an enclosed
ATX case with an ambient room
temperature of 21°. The ASRock Steel
Legend and Sapphire Nitro Plus both
reported a GPU hotspot temperature of
79° with a fan speed of 1,000 RPM. And
both models were extremely quiet and
couldn't be heard over our case fans,
which are very quiet. The ASUS Prime
could be just heard over the case fans
as its fans spun at 1550 RPM. Though
this did result in a GPU hotspot
temperature of just 70°. Then we have
the XFX Swift, which spun its fans at
1400 RPM for a hotspot temperature of
just 69°. And this model also managed to
clock its cores the highest. Then for
the memory, the ASRock Steel Legend
peaked at 85 degrees, the ASUS Prime at
82 degrees, the XFX Swift at 80 degrees,
and then the Sapphire Nitro Plus at
84°. Then finally, the VRM temperatures
of the Steel Legend hit 75°, just 62°
for the Prime, 71° for the Swift, and
75° for the Sapphire Nitro Plus. Okay,
time for the cost per frame data. And
we'll start with the MSRP because I just
like to see where everything should sit
if all models were available at the
suggested retail price. What we see here
is that if the 960 XT 16 GB was
available for $350 US and all other GPUs
were available at their MSRP, the 9060
XT would represent incredible value.
Firstly, it's by far the cheapest
current generation GPU to offer 16 GB of
VRAM. And the significance of this isn't
really presented by the cost per frame
data, as a lot of the games tested still
work fine with 8 GB of VRAM, which is
true of most games, but of course, not
all. And it's becoming increasingly
common to find games that are broken on
8 GB GPUs using settings that would
otherwise be fine had those GPUs had
more VRAM. But all of that aside, the
9060 XT still looks very good here,
coming in at a cost per frame of just
$5, just a 6% premium over Intel's Arc
B580, making that part a tough sell if
all models were available at the MSRP.
The 9060 XT 16 GB also eliminates the
RTX 5060. It's just $50 US more, but
offers almost 30% more performance with
twice the VRAM. So, a no-brainer there.
And the margin between the 5060 and the
960 XT 16 GB will vary depending on the
games tested because in a lot of the
games that we did use for testing at
1440p the 8 GB GPUs were limited by
their VRAM. But moving on, it was also
17% better value per frame than the 5060
Ti 16 GB, which we feel makes the Radeon
GPU the better value option and
therefore the product you should buy if
the MSRP was a thing. So, if all models
were available at the MSRP, the 960 XT
16 GB would be the budget GPU to
get. But what about real retail pricing?
Well, of course, right now, we just have
no idea how much the 960 XT will cost.
We also don't know how long it'll take
before pricing settles down. So, I've
come up with a few different pricing
scenarios here, which we compare with
the other parts and see where things
sit. Now, of course, there is the $350
US MSRP, which I'm sure some models will
be available for for a limited time. And
then we'll have some more expensive,
probably more realistic pricing options
at $390 and then $430 US to go up
against the 5060 Ti 16 GB, which
currently costs $480 US. Obviously, if
you're in a position to snap up a 9060
XT 16 GB at the MSRP, then do so because
as things stand right now, it's offering
26% better value than the 5060 Ti 16 GB.
Now, if the price happens to be more
like $390 US, which is an 11% premium
over MSRP, and that's the same premium
the 5060 Ti 16 GB currently sits over
MSRP, the 9060 XT in that situation ends
up offering 18% better value, which
still makes it the obvious choice in my
opinion. But if the price heads more
towards $430 US, that'll see the 9060 XT
offering just 9% better value than the
5060 Ti. And at that point, I'd probably
just buy the GeForce GPU, or at the very
least, it becomes an option. So, as
things stand, AMD does need to keep the
price below $400 US. And of course, we
will continue to monitor pricing, and
we'll have a pricing update video for
you next month where we can re-evaluate
this situation. AMD claimed that the
performance of the Radeon RX960 XT would
be similar to the GeForce RTX 5060Ti.
And thankfully, those claims appear to
be spot on as I saw virtually identical
performance at
1440p. So, for me, the 9060 XT 16 GB
really does tick all the boxes. That is
assuming AMD can supply enough product
to meet the demand, which might not be
the case for the first few months, but
beyond that, we really do hope they can.
And assuming they can, this will be the
GPU to get in the current climate. $350
US for the 960 XT makes it the ultimate
budget GPU. Firstly, you're getting 7700
XT light performance from a card with 16
GB of VRAM. You're also getting FSR4 and
greatly improved rateracing performance.
Though at this performance tier RT
performance is highly dubious even on
the 5060 Ti as these GPUs really aren't
powerful enough to offer a
transformative experience. And short of
that, you might as well just disable RT
effects and enjoy the higher FPS with
lower latency. But opinions will of
course vary on that one. But with an
average of 70 FPS across the 18 games
tested at native 1440p, the 960 XT is
certainly capable. This also made it 43%
faster than the 7600 XT, AMD's previous
generation entry-level 16 GB part. So,
that's a massive performance uplift for
what should be a 6% price premium. As it
stands, the 960 XT 16 GB should be the
cheapest GPU anyone buys. Saving the $50
to get the RTX 5060 or 960 XT 8 GB. It's
really like throwing money away at this
point. And I'm not mocking or attacking
anyone who can't afford to spend the
additional $50 US. Rather, I'd rather
that you don't have to spend the
additional $50 US, I guess, is the point
I'm trying to make. I would prefer the
16 GB model just be the base model. And
this is because we've seen in the past
with parts like the 40 62 8 and 16 GB
that the 8 GB versions do depreciate
much faster and are harder to sell due
to less demand because, you know, 8 GB
cards kind of suck now. Therefore, years
from now, I strongly suspect that the 8
GB versions of the 1960 XT and
5060Ti are not only going to be more
difficult to sell, they'll also sell for
much less than the 14% saving they offer
today. Again, I'm not talking down to
anyone who can't afford to spend the
extra money on the 16 GB model. If
anything, I'm advocating for AMD and
Nvidia to offer better products at
better prices. Particularly in the case
of the 960 XT, GDDR6 memory is both
plentiful and affordable. So, there's
really no reason why a base model 960 XT
can't offer 16 GB of VRAM for $300 US.
There's also the issue of these models
sharing the same name, a practice that
has become increasingly anti-consumer
the more inadequate the base model has
become. Again, 8 GB GPUs in 2025 is a
joke, and branding them as X-T and TI
models makes the situation even worse.
On that note, if you are interested in
the 9060 XT because you like the
performance you've seen here in this
review, please be extremely careful when
buying as you don't want to end up with
an 8 GB card. And I'll show you just how
trash that product is in a video
tomorrow. But before then, please be
careful when sorting online listings by
cheapest first. Make sure you skip all
of the 8 GB
models. Sadly, the 8 GB version really
has tainted the release of the 960 XT.
There really should be nothing bad to
say about this product, at least, you
know, given current market conditions.
But, of course, AMD did an AMD thing,
which in this case was to miss the
opportunity to flawlessly crush Nvidia's
popular 5060 series. But at least the 16
GB model looks pretty good at at least
at the suggested retail price. We just
have to wait and see if that is a real
price. And I guess until then, I'm just
going to have to reserve judgment. So
with that, I am done with this review.
If you liked it, you know what to do. We
also have the 8 GB model coming
tomorrow. So I'll get to show
you all about that thing. We have a lot
of new testing in that video, so that
should be interesting. So like I said,
make sure you're subscribed. Also, we
have the join button or Patreon if you
want to become a Harbor Box member. will
get you access to our exclusive Discord
server, monthly live streams, Q&A stuff,
and behind the scenes content. So, check
that out. If you're interested, if
that's perfectly fine, and I would like
to thank you for watching this video.
I'm your host, Steve. See you again next
time.
[Music]